tous regrettent shalev a permis six mois
j'étais en train de péter la gueule en
sommeil carnac les gens sur une sa g
vous les avez vus ils sont très nombreux
ils sont partout je parle bien
évidemment des fake des gens qui usurpe
notre identité à nos grands youtuber
célèbre comment hostile fois de carrière
pour squeeze il profite de l'innocence
des plus jeunes d'entre nous vous rendez
vous compte alors sur youtube
excellent site qui permet à deux
personnes d'avoir exactement le même
pseudo sa balance larnack se fait sous
forme de cliquer sur ma photo alors
pourquoi ils veulent tant que vous
cliquez sur la photo mais je vais vous
dire youtube permet aux youtuber de
taper des mots qui seront bannis c'est à
dire si tu postes un commentaire qui
contient ce moto comme auteur ne passera
pas il dégage immédiatement à la sortie
ça rentre chez soi on aurait dit une
phrase d'un recul et de racisme et non
bref [ __ ] en fait nous on sera six ou
sur les arnaques là en tapant la
commande étoiles links étoiles dans les
mots bannis sahbani automatiquement tous
les commentaires qui comportent des
liens donc là les arnaqueurs il était en
pls ils sont donc 10 mai au pire on leur
demande de cliquer sur notre photo en se
faisant passer pour youtube heures en
question et on arrive sur notre chaîne y
aura une vidéo absolument dégueulasse en
anglais qui les incitera se faire
arnaquer restent sûrs a même choisi vous
promesses à un truc de malade faut
cliquer sur un lien machin tu te faire
un hacker bref morale de l'histoire ne
cliquez jamais sur la photo de profil
youtube heures comme ça plus vite ça et
c'est vrai ça dégagement toutes les
arnaques on n'en parle plus bref nous
aussi on a été jeune et nous aussi on
sera vieux et dans les deux cas la
technologie nous dépasse un peu on n'est
pas habitué on n'a pas eu beaucoup
d'expérience avec donc on peut
facilement se faire avoir mais ça m'est
arrivé quand j'étais petit mais je vous
en parlais appris pendant qu'on attendra
quelque chose deuxième type d' arnaque
sur instagram quand vous suivez un
youtuber connu france et qui est très
beau et dont les vidéos sont absolument
extraordinaires je parle bien sûr de
squeeze qu'il ya automatiquement des
bottes qui vont vous follow mais c'est
presque immédiat enfin j'espère sinon
cette vidéo est nul à chier tu es gens
se font passer pour nous avons essayé de
vous contacter et de vous faire croire
qu'on fait gagner un iphone pas un
samsung un iphone les amis ce qui va se
passer aujourd'hui ça va être hyper
sérieux pas comme ces lunettes et
daredevil aurait pas trop du match les
notes mais qu il a présenté le plus de
respect moyenne va infiltrer le réseau
d'arnaqueurs et le détruire par
l'intérieur attention étape une créé un
faux compte in the rain bienvenue sur
instagram je me suis créé un compte qui
s'appelle baptiste l'obg du 78 parce que
comex appel baptiste et qu il n 78 il
est beau gosse finalement on va ajouter
une photo qui va faire quoi
je suis très fan de minecraft conseil va
vraiment croire je suis une cible facile
extrêmement jeunes voix c'est très bien
ça étape 2 paul hodé youtuber français
[Musique]
étape 3 attendre qu'un petit fdp mordent
à l'hameçon au alors [ __ ] squeeze
monsieur max ouais c'est vraiment lui
c'est sa force et sa photo officielle et
où sont passé le mot
ok donc vous l'aurez compris ce sont des
gens qui se font passer pour nous sur
ims ta g et qui font défaut concours
d'iphone cette voie là mais pour
participer au concours il faut que tu
appelles un numéro payant et tu lui
donnes le code cantons a donné au
téléphone quand on a payé trois euros
voilà tôt mais je suis con on est mal
infiltrés chéri j'ai posté aucune photo
sur le compte et j'ai même pas mis de
description je suis passé sur tablette
car ne pouvons pas voir les messages des
conversations sur instagram coach belge
poste une photo de moi même ça n'a aucun
sens ce qui se passe ou avait un genre
que je suis très très très fan comme ça
le mec va vraiment très très s'enflammer
donc je tombe dans son piège du faux
concours c'est très drôle voilà au
regarder s'il ya dans ma t elle put un
atout elle fait gagner tellement
d'iphone geof des iphone cette baisse au
1er mai commente moi je vous aime mes
fans bonne chance à tous mais t'as pas
autant qu les [ __ ] mais quelle bâtard
alors en attendant qu'ils me contacter
par message plus et je voulais vous
raconter une anecdote qui m'est arrivé
quand j'étais petit j'ai fait me faire
avoir quand j'étais plus jeune par un
spam de cette technique marche à tous
les coups
gagner à la roulette grâce à la
technique de david la purge as j'étais
descendu en courant chez moi pour aller
prendre la carte bleue de ma mère pour
lui dire oui parce que la banque était
bien faite il te permettait de jouer un
coup gratuitement et la technique marché
c'est que c'est truqué mais quand tu
mettais d'everett une ça marchait plus
nat ou g maintenant coucou tu veux
participer pour gagner l'iphone est
celle gratuitement comme les autres fans
espèces 2002 ya que moi qui comptais pas
photo c'est le mythomane
oh oui j'aimerais bien jeux marquants
graille tous absolument ignobles mais
j'ai envie de voir à quel point ils
prennent les gens pour des cons ces
sales bêtes de scène mais comment je
peux savoir que c'est vraiment dahico
riche trop android à de corriger ce que
j'écris c'est chiant d'accord tu dois me
suivre étape par étape pour que tu
puisse recevoir ton iphone
après 48 heures de ta participation
d'accor en tout cas pas après que tu ai
appris à bien parler français salon est
infiltré on doit pas s'énerver puis
intéressé par quelle couleur noire
prouve moi que tu es bien à tous c'est
mon deuxième quand je l'écris pour la
compétition des fans et c'est moi
personnellement qui a choisi les
participants ça n'a aucun sens je vais
pas avec le micro ça marche et pourquoi
tu ne le fait pas sur ton compte
principal j'ai trop courtes d'un coup
j'écris parfaitement bien française
génial c'est bien maintenant pour
confirmer la participation du système de
demandes dit code reçu gratuitement par
téléphone
code on doit pas y avoir beaucoup de
gens qui tombent dans le piège pour qui
demande autant de codes mais qu un code
ces genres deux ou trois ans vous rendez
compte sa fusée mais c'est encore plus
des fils de [ __ ] que ce que je pensais
au fait tu perds tu réponds quoi et
pourquoi tu ne fais pas surtout qu'on
principal l'abandonnent espèce de lâche
salut tu veux quoi comme offre le iphone
6 aces ou l'iphone 7 aces ou galaxy s
est où le galaxy s ou es vite s'te plaît
et je vais demander si c'est vraiment ce
qu'on faisait quand même c'est bizarre
on a tous qui nous répond parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de fans qui a participé
c'est pas le but d'un concours qui est
le plus fun possible qu'ils participent
voilà appelle ses numéros à garder il
donne vite les numéros en mode a besoin
d'autres questions vas-y je vais te tout
fait appel trois fois il ya un mec qui
va te dire le code d'accès tu me passes
correctes le prix qu'ils vont te dire à
chaque appel 3 0 c'est juste pour les
publicités des marseillais puis service
illimité inquiète c'est gratuit l'appel
hockey waouh c'est génial mais moi le
truc de la roulette que je m'étais fait
avoir c'était au moins bien foutu là
c'est juste la grosse merde le prix
qu'ils vont te dire à chaque appel 3
euros c'est juste pour la publicité des
marseillais chikhou ba plus service
illimité ça n'a encore moins de sens
avec cette phrase je suis désolé du coup
c'est la publicité des marseillais qui
paye les 3 euros à ma place en fait
d'après lui franchement gros bisous à
tous les marseillais vous est archi
simple cheptel gagnant l'iphone grâce
house est tellement cool
attends je vais la mener en bateau
prouve moi que c'est toi envoient moins
une photo et je te fais 30 code
j'ai vraiment envie de gagner l'iphone
il va devenir fou oui avec plaisir mais
on doit d'abord termine la participation
mec je veux pas participer à savoir que
c'est vraiment toi [ __ ] mais je vais
pas participer avant de savoir que c'est
vraiment toi envoient moins une photo
s'il te plaît mec d'un coup j'ai écrit
parfaitement français il va crois que
c'est la police il a pratiqué je sais
pas où ils sont ces gens là mais non
ménard est de dire ce que je dis google
arrête de faire griller la filtration a
raté ou pompes et de conversations
désolé squeeze hochart élu pire employés
du fbi ya quatre années consécutives
elle m'a envoyé une vidéo c'est quoi ça
au sud iphone 7 ce n'est pas du fait qu
appelé bien les numéros écoutez bien les
codes données bien toutes les
informations allez sur concours tiré du
bac ont gagné tiré du bagad iphone cet
au revoir
mais ses origines mais mec c'est affreux
comme uma et comme ils manipulent des
enfants quoi mais carla alors là ou
alors au [ __ ] mais ça ne prouve pas
que c'est toi je veux une photo de toi
avec marc et iphone 7 sur une feuille
blanche que tu tiens entre tes mains
est ce que cet homme est vraiment fort
et va réussir à [ __ ] le chopper je
veux voir jusqu'où ils vous en faites
[ __ ] mais que l'enfant cyclo klaauw la
série recouche tu choisis parmi mes fans
pour un cadeau choisi la couleur que tu
veux iphone cette noire où il est en
train de me répondre
alors quel pays all bat tard il veut
gagner en crédibilité en faisant ce
genre quel pays quelle adresse à
peut-être c'est compliqué a atteint je
lui donnais un pays hyper pomey vatican
si je lui dis fatigant et ce qui y est
je suis un fake weeds est ok pas de
souci c'est un enfant du vatican vatican
c'est une grippe a il est génial
alors je suis désolé de vous dire qu'on
a perdu un atout qui a vu mon message
mais qui ne m'a pas répondu
nate où je suis vraiment très déçu
cyprien a vu vaty grand prix attends je
vais tenter une blague je rigole france
oui le mec a vu 26 quand il a vraiment
appeler son manager ou [ __ ] est un mec
au vatican qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est
peut-être la police qui est en train
d'infiltrer le réseau
tu dois terminer maintenant sinon le
système va te bloquer mes mecs cessé d
[ __ ] y met une pression de ouf quoi
aux gens non stop le attend va lui
envoyer une vidéo non mais ça te plait
juste arc c'est toi je te fais l'école
je veux te plaît ok la vidéo est renvoyé
il doit se dire [ __ ] j'ai le bon bol
hausse du jour au [ __ ] il est en train
d'écrire
qu'est-ce qui va répondre à ça est ce
que ma vidéo la touche en plein car il
va abandonner son projet d'arnaqué un
enfant sans défense c'est moi mon
capteurs marche pas fais moi confiance
si tu termines des codes tu vas rien
payé pourquoi d'un coup il écrit bien
français il pense que ça me convoque
mais tu as publié une story un style à 2
minutes vous avoue que je suis content
parce que j'ai en train de faire perdre
son temps un gros connard de merde car
aucune race au clavier il est au clavier
oui mais avec un autre téléphone va
connecte toi sur l'autre téléphone
lol alors quelle va être la prochaine et
ce que je pense qu'elle sera aussi
crédible que moi quand je voulais de
faire mes devoirs en cinquième pas
maintenant je suis en compétition
il me fatigue plus tard pour faire ça
ils prennent les mecs ou avant la pire
un pro de tous les temps comme
incroyable compétition de quoi
gymnastique lol agenais à son niveau
mais qui s'est clairement des gens qui
sont dans d'autres pays quoi au revoir
ils aiment tellement pas les blagues
entre vatican et gymnastique gens
peuvent plus que tu lui dis qu'ils aient
un gymnase du vatican c'est bon ils
suicide le mec les amuser à facettes
infiltration au sein d'un réseau
d'arnaqueurs et surtout de gens très
très borné 1 ne s'est pas aimé la vidéo
si elle vous a plu j'ai essayé d'en
parler en s'amusant ne tombez pas dans
le piège de gens qui veulent vous
arnaquer en se faisant passer pour des
youtuber en plus la plupart des youtuber
sûr maintenant certifié sur les réseaux
et quand bien même il ne le serait pas
on vous fera jamais gagner des trucs ta
gueule squeeze ta gueule on vous fera
jamais gagner des trucks en échange de
code c'est impossible que ce soit sur
une salle g sur youtube sur twitter bref
n'importe sur internet ne cliquez pas
sur des liens bizarre sur des espèces de
concours ça n'existe pas personne ne
fait ça je suis désolé pour toute
élection tomber dans le piège de ces
gros fdp au moins ça sert de leçon ça
vous arrivera plus faut voir le positif
c'est vrai quoi si ma mère m'avait dit
oui jour là bim elle perdait 5 ans balle
bref le message est passé je vais
chercher mon chèque auprès du fn
je vous dis à bientôt pour lost aura pas
de chèque
ok nouvelle vidéo mon jeu
je me suis fait virer du fbi
[Musique]